nos piden que estimemos a que es
aproximadamente igual 2.7 por 4 pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar la respuesta
bueno podemos pensar que 2.7 x 4 es casi
igual a algunos dicen aproximadamente
igual a bueno 2.7 es 2 unidades y 7
decimos y tenemos que pensar en cuál es
el número entero más cercano a 2.7 bueno
2.7 es muy cercano a 3 de hecho es más
cercano a 3 de lo que es a 2 por lo
tanto podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 3 por 4 y 3 por
4 por supuesto es igual a 12 puedes ver
que las otras opciones son poco
razonables 1.2 bueno si tomo algo y lo
multiplicó por cuatro en definitiva no
obtengo un resultado que sea menor que
mi algo original y si tomo al que es
aproximadamente 3 por 4 no obtengo 120
como aproximación eso no tiene sentido y
mucho menos 1200
así que hagamos otro ejemplo bueno aquí
nos preguntan a qué es casi igual o
aproximadamente igual la multiplicación
de 78 x 19.88 pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta
bien apliquemos la misma idea queremos
pensar cuáles son los números a los que
se acercan estos otros números que sean
más fáciles de multiplicar por ejemplo
78 es muy cercano a 80 y 19.88 o 19
enteros y 88 centésimos es muy cercano a
20 es más cercano a 20 de lo que es a 19
incluso si fuera más cercano a 19 para
estimar prefiero hacerlo con 20 que con
19 porque es más fácil multiplicar por
20 así que este es cercano a 20 y
entonces todo esto es aproximadamente
igual a 80 por 20 y estoy seguro que
reconocerá que esto es lo mismo que 8
por 2 por 10 por 10
de hecho lo escribiré así para no
saltarme pasos aunque normalmente lo
hacemos en nuestra mente 80 es lo mismo
que 8 por 10 por 2 por 10 y podemos
decir que esto será igual a bueno 8 por
2 es 16 y 10 por 10 es 100
entonces 16% que es 1600 lo cual es el
inciso c veamos los demás sencillos para
darnos cuenta de que tenemos la razón
primero no tiene sentido que tomemos un
número cercano a 80 y lo multiplicamos
por un número cercano a 20 y que
obtengamos de resultado un número menor
que 80 de igual manera un número cercano
a 80 para llegar a 160 tenemos que
multiplicarlo por un número cercano a 2
pero aquí estamos multiplicando por algo
cercano a 20 por último para ir de algo
cercano a 80 hasta 16.000 entonces no
tenemos que multiplicar por algo cercano
a 20 tenemos que multiplicar por algo
cercano a 200 así que si me gusta
nuestra respuesta